there's a new driving force in the auto
industry Italian American company Fiat
Chrysler and French firm PSA the maker
of peugeot used to be rivals but after
months of talks they've agreed on a
fifty billion dollar merger the firms
expected to produce eight point seven
million vehicles a year making it the
world's fourth largest automaker ahead
of Ford and General Motors the SI boss
carlos tavares will become the new chief
executive of the firm the newly combined
company will have fourteen different
makes of vehicle including peugeot
citroen alfa romeo and jeep but given
the large number of overlapping brands
the overall downturn in global sales and
the cost of researching and developing
electric and driverless cars there's a
risk some of these brands won't survive
PSA and Fiat Chrysler are aiming for
annual cost savings of four billion
dollars by combining technology the
company say there are no plans to close
factories but Britain's biggest union is
already seeking guarantees for the
Vauxhall brand and analysts say jobs
could be at risk the numbers for me done
it up they have a significant learning
curve if you like in terms of cutting
their emissions and investing in
electric vehicles and meeting climate
targets while at the same time only
making savings of 3.7 billion euros
they're gonna need an awful lot more
investment to address those challenges
the entire industry is steering rapidly
away from fossil fuels car makers such
as Tesla have been leading the pack with
a new generation of affordable electric
vehicles other big-name brands are
quickly catching up but it takes
expensive research and development to
remain competitive the car industry is
at a crossroads PSA and Fiat Chrysler
hope the alliance will help them handle
uncertain new terrain NIMH Barca
al-jazeera London